The following content is
provided by MIT OpenCourseWare
under a Creative Commons
license.
Additional information about
our license and MIT
OpenCourseWare in general is
available at ocw.mit.edu.
Last time we started talking
about the internal motions of
molecules, the vibrations and
the rotations.
And we talked about how the
different ways in which a
molecule can store energy were
called modes.
Or, sometimes called the
degrees of freedom.
And so, in general,
if we have a molecule that has
N atoms, it has 3N degrees of
freedom or 3N modes.
And we said last time,
that three of those 3N modes
are always translational modes.
We live in a three-dimensional
universe, so there are three
translational modes,
three directions in which the
molecule can travel,
can move.
And, therefore,
if we use three of these 3N
modes for translation,
then we have 3 minus 3 modes
that are internal modes,
internal degrees of freedom.
And that is what we really want
to start looking at today.
On the diagram here,
on the side,
here is our N molecule.
There are 3N total modes.
I just said three of them were
translational modes.
Now, how do we separate those
remaining modes between rotation
and vibration?
The way we do it this.
If you have a molecule that is
linear, you always have two
rotational modes.
I will show you that in a
moment.
Linear molecules always have
two rotational modes.
Nonlinear molecules have three
rotational modes.
Therefore, if we use,
in a linear molecule,
three of them for translation,
two of them for rotation,
the number of vibrational modes
are what is left over.
For a linear molecule,
we have 3N minus 5 vibrational
modes.
If we have a nonlinear
molecule, since we have three
rotational modes in a nonlinear
molecule, we have leftover 3N
minus 6 vibrational
modes.
Now, let's take a look at this
a little bit more in detail.
Let's start with nitrogen.
Two atoms.
Six modes total.
Three translational.
Two rotational modes of
nitrogen.
What are those rotational
modes?
Well, here is our nitrogen.
And one of those rotational
modes is going to be rotation
about an axis in the plane of
this board, and its rotation
around this axis.
That axis goes through the
center of mass of that molecule.
That is one of the rotational
modes.
Another rotational mode is
rotation around an axis,
here, that is perpendicular to
the board.
This is another rotational
mode.
It is going to turn out that
these two rotational modes are
degenerate, meaning they are
going to have the same frequency
of rotation.
They are going to have the same
energy.
We will talk about that in a
moment.
What I want to point out,
here, is that if you look at
the axis, here,
in the plane of the board that
is along the bond axis,
this, hey, you know what,
this is not a rotational mode
because there is cylindrical
symmetry around that bond axis.
It has no meaning,
rotation around that bond axis.
The molecule looks the same for
all of the angles from zero to
360 degrees.
That is not a rotational mode.
Linear molecules,
diatomics, you have two
rotational modes.
They are going to turn out to
be degenerate,
as we are going to see.
And then, our table over there
says for nitrogen,
we ought to have one
vibrational mode.
And we do.
That one vibrational mode,
here, is the nitrogen-nitrogen
stretch.
It is a stretch mode.
We said last time that these
bonds function like a spring.
The molecule can stretch,
the molecule can compress.
We are going to look at that in
more detail in just a moment.
Next, in our table over here,
let's look at CO two.
CO two has three atoms.
Nine total modes.
Three of them are translation.
CO two,
even though it has three atoms
in it, is a linear molecule,
so it has only two rotational
modes.
Let's look and see what those
two rotational modes are.
One of those rotational modes
is, again, rotation around an
axis in the plane of the board,
here, around the center of mass
of that molecule.
That is one rotational mode.
The other rotational mode is
around an axis perpendicular to
the board here.
That is a second rotational
mode.
These two modes are going to be
degenerate because they are
actually the same motion,
just in a different plane.
These are degenerate.
And then, again,
just to emphasize,
if you think that you have a
rotation here along that linear
bond axis, well,
the answer is no,
this is not a rotational mode.
So, we have two rotational
modes for CO two.
And now what does our table say
in terms of vibration?
Well, in terms of vibration for
a linear molecule,
3N minus 5,
we have used now five modes.
We have four left,
3N minus 5.
What are those modes?
One of these modes is what we
call a symmetric stretch.
A symmetric stretch means that
this oxygen and this oxygen are
simultaneously stretching or are
simultaneously compressing.
My body is the carbon,
and my arms are the oxygen.
A symmetric stretch is the
oxygens both moving in or both
moving out.
That is one vibrational mode,
this symmetric stretch.
That is one vibrational mode.
What is another vibrational
mode?
Well, if you have a symmetric
stretch, it must mean you have
an anti-symmetric stretch.
In this case,
we have one oxygen moving out
while the other oxygen is moving
in.
And this carbon is kind of
moving in like that,
too.
Or, this one is moving in,
this one is moving in,
this one is moving out.
That is the anti-symmetric
stretch.
If my body is the carbon and my
arms are the oxygen,
this is the anti-symmetric
stretch with the carbon moving
just a little bit to the side,
too.
The anti-symmetric stretch,
another mode.
These two modes are not
degenerate.
They have different
frequencies.
They have different energies.
We will see that in a moment.
What are the other modes?
Well, the other modes are a
bending mode.
What can happen is that this
oxygen and this oxygen can move
in, and this carbon will kind of
move out.
Or, of course,
the other way,
here.
These go like that,
this goes like that,
or that goes like that.
This is a bending vibration.
Again, if my body is the carbon
and these are the oxygens,
the bending vibration looks
like this.
That is the bending vibration.
However, you could also imagine
that you have a bend in another
plane.
In other words,
you can imagine that these two
oxygens here are coming out at
you or going in at you.
And so, in other words,
if I am the carbon,
these are the oxygens.
We also have a bend like this.
These two bending vibrations
are degenerate.
These are four different
vibrations.
They are the four vibrational
modes, two bending,
one symmetric stretch,
and the other,
the anti-symmetric stretch.
That is what we have in
CO two.
What about another molecule?
How about water?
We have three atoms.
Again, nine total modes.
Three of them are translation,
but now water is not a linear
molecular.
So, we are going to have three
rotational modes in the case of
water.
Let's look at what those three
rotational modes ought to look
like.
Here is our water molecule.
One of those rotations is,
again, a rotation around an
axis here in the plane of the
board.
That is one rotational mode.
If I am the oxygen and my hands
are the hydrogen,
this is a rotational mode.
You got that?
Okay.
And then another rotational
mode, here.
It can be a rotation around the
center of the mass,
centered on the oxygen here.
Axis perpendicular to the plane
of the board.
This is that rotation.
And I am sorry,
but I cannot do cartwheels.
That is one rotational mode.
And then a final rotational
mode involves rotation,
now, around this axis.
It is an axis perpendicular to
this one, but in the plane of
the board.
And this is a rotational mode.
We have three rotational modes.
This one requires me to do some
flips, which I am also not going
to do.
But each one of these modes has
a different frequency,
has a different energy.
And you can see we have three
of them now because we no longer
have a linear molecule.
We have three rotational modes.
Now, what about the vibrations
for water?
Well, you can see from our
graph up here that 3N minus 6,
in this case for
water, is going to be three
vibrational modes.
Let's look at that.
One of those vibrational modes
is a symmetric stretch,
again.
The hydrogen is moving in or
both moving out at the same
time.
A picture of the symmetric
stretch is, again,
I am the oxygen,
arms are the hydrogen.
This is the symmetric stretch,
right?
And then, if there is a
symmetric stretch,
there is going to be an
anti-symmetric stretch.
What that means is one of the
hydrogens is moving in and the
other one moving out.
Or, this way.
Of course, a picture for that
is this kind of a motion.
You get the idea.
Anti-symmetric stretch.
And then, finally,
we have a bending mode.
A bending mode,
meaning these hydrogens moving
this way or those hydrogens
moving that way.
And, of course,
a picture for that is this.
That is a bending mode for the
hydrogens.
We have three vibrational modes
for the hydrogen.
Now we are going to look at
some of the principles behind
these internal degrees of
freedom.
But, of course,
the other reason for telling
you about this-- Did you have a
question?
It can, but it is not a
separate mode.
That is correct.
That is right.
It looks like a rotation,
actually.
That is absolutely correct.
The other reason for talking
about this is to tell you that
each one of these vibrations or
rotations occurs at a frequency
at an energy that is
characteristic of the molecule.
If we had a way to actually
measure the frequency of these
vibrations or the frequencies of
the rotations,
well, then we have a great tool
for identifying what kind of
molecule we have.
Analytically,
this is a wonderful technique
for identifying,
ultimately, the molecule that
you have, if you can measure
those frequencies of vibration
or rotation.
And we are going to do that in
just a moment.
But what we also have to
understand, before we go and
measure these frequencies,
is we have to understand that
the energies with which a
molecule vibrates or rotates are
quantized.
So, that is what we have to
spend some time thinking about
right now.
Let's do that.
And we are going to start with
vibration.
To illustrate this,
I am going to draw one of these
energies of interaction,
again, one of these curves that
we have been talking about.
And I am going to set my zero
of energy at the dissociated
atom limit.
So, I am going to talk about H
plus Cl.
And, of course,
right here, we talked about
this being the equilibrium bond
length, r sub e,
for the HCl molecule.
That is the energy of
interaction.
I am going to now draw in the
ground vibrational state of HCl,
which I am going to represent
as a line.
It is going to be the energy.
There is the ground vibrational
state of HCl.
The ground vibrational state,
that energy is characterized by
a quantum number.
The quantum number is the
vibrational quantum number for
the ground vibrational state.
The vibrational quantum number
is v equal zero.
What this line represents is
the ground vibrational energy.
It also represents the extent
to which the molecule's bond
stretches and compresses.
The bottom line,
here, is that the bond
stretches up to here.
The inner section of this line
with the interaction energy,
here, represents the maximum
distance of the bond,
the maximum bond length,
the most that the bond
stretches.
r is going this way.
The intersection of this energy
with this curve represents the
closest that the two nuclei get.
This represents the most that
the molecule has compressed.
This is the smallest value of
r.
That is what that diagram
represents.
If you start out,
here, with an HCl molecule at
the equilibrium bond length,
right here, what happens is
that the HCl will stretch,
and it will stretch to this
position.
This is an exaggeration.
This is how much it stretches.
And then, it comes back and
goes through the equilibrium
position.
Over here, and this is another
exaggeration,
this is how close they get to
each other.
This is how much they compress.
This point is often called the
inner turning point,
inner because it is the
smallest bond distance.
This is often called the outer
turning point because it is the
larger bond distance.
It is outer because it is at
this distance,
now, that the bond turns around
and begins to compress.
This HCl molecule here is
vibrating, equilibrium position.
Then it goes to the maximum
extension, comes back through
the equilibrium position,
and then goes to the maximum
compression, comes back to the
equilibrium position.
That is what this line
literally represents.
It is also the energy,
which I will explain a little
bit more in just a moment.
So, this molecule is vibrating
from here to here to here and
back and forth.
Now, what I also want to point
out to you is something that I
have been kind of misleading you
about for the last few weeks.
That is that this molecule is
not sitting in the bottom of
this well.
Remember that when we were
drawing bond association
energies, I was drawing it from
the bottom of this well to the
dissociated atom limit?
I told you this was delta E sub
d.
Well, the bottom line is that
it is not really correct.
The reason is,
is because the molecule is
never really sitting at the
bottom of this well.
It is sitting this much above.
It is sitting at the v equal
zero state.
It is not sitting at the bottom
of the well.
If it were, it would not be
vibrating.
If it is not vibration,
it will violate the Uncertainty
Principle, something we didn't
talk about.
But the bottom line is that it
cannot sit at the bottom of the
well.
It is always vibrating by about
this much energy.
When you have an experimentally
determined dissociation energy
for the bond energy,
the experimentally determined
energy is actually the energy
from this level.
From v equal zero up
to this dissociation limit.
This is the experimental bond
energy.
Because, if you are going to
measure a bond energy in the
laboratory, well,
you can only measure it from
the lowest level at which that
molecule can possibly be at.
It is not at the bottom of the
well.
The difference between where
this level is and the bottom of
the well actually has a name.
That difference is called the
zero point energy.
And I will explain that in a
moment, when we look at the
energies a little more
carefully.
Now, just for completeness,
and this is not something that
you have to know,
let me tell you what the
nomenclature usually is here for
these well depths.
The nomenclature from the
bottom of the well to here,
which is not experimentally
measured, is usually D sub e,
dissociation sub e.
From the v equal zero
level to the dissociation limit,
that energy here is D sub zero.
You don't have to know these,
but I just want to tell you,
when you see that.
All dissociation energies
experimentally measured are
measured from here to here
because that is the lowest
energy the molecule can have,
is being in the v equal zero
ground vibrational
state.
Well, now let's take a look at
the energies a little more
carefully.
Here is our favorite diagram
again, our intermolecular
interaction potential.
This is HCl,
so here is the dissociated atom
limit.
This is v equal zero,
right in there.
Now, there is an excited state
for the HCl, or for any
molecule.
v equal one is the first
vibrationally excited state.
v equal two is the
second vibrationally excited
state.
v equal three is the
third.
v equal four is the
fourth.
v equal five is the
fifth.
These are the allowed
vibrational energies.
In other words,
the molecule can vibrate with
this energy or this energy or
this energy, but not some
arbitrary energy,
like right in here or like
right in there.
These are the allowed
vibrational states.
And we have a nice analytical
expression to describe those
energies.
That analytical expression is
right here.
That energy is h times nu times
(that vibrational quantum number
plus one-half).
So, v is that vibrational
quantum number.
This nu, here,
is the fundamental frequency,
which is the frequency with
which the molecule vibrates.
It is the frequency with which
that molecule stretches,
comes back to the equilibrium
position, compresses,
and comes back to the
equilibrium position.
It is the number of cycles per
second that molecule makes.
So, nu is the number of cycles,
here, that the molecule in v
equal zero makes per
second.
Stretches, compresses,
and back to the equilibrium
position.
Notice it is also the
vibrational frequency of v equal
one.
The vibrational frequency does
not depend on the vibrational
quantum number.
You see no dependence of the
vibrational quantum number on
the frequency.
v equal two vibrates
with the same frequency.
v equal three.
v equal four.
v equal five.
All of these states have the
same nu here,
have the same fundamental
frequency.
What does that mean?
That looks a little strange in
the sense that if you have a
molecule in v equals zero,
the number of cycles per second
that it makes is the same as a
molecule in v equal five.
Well, you can see that in v
equal five, the molecule has to
stretch further,
and it has to compress further.
It has to travel more distance.
And so, if it has to travel
more distance,
but it still carries out the
number of cycles per unit time,
the same as v equal zero,
well, then it must mean that
the molecule in v equal five is
moving more quickly,
is moving faster.
And that is what that means.
The energy of this state is
higher.
It is moving faster.
But it is moving with the same
frequency nu.
That is the fundamental
frequency.
That fundamental frequency,
of course, is in hertz,
our unit for all frequencies
here.
Now, I drew on the board and
called this energy from the
bottom of the well to v equal
zero, the zero point energy.
That is what it is.
But numerically what that
energy is, is one-half h nu.
Stick in v equal zero,
you get one-half h nu.
This energy,
here, is measured from the
bottom of this well.
It is important that you
understand where this energy is
measured from.
It is measured from the bottom
of this well.
v equal one,
you put that in here and get
three-halves h nu.
v equal two,
you get five-halves h nu.
v equal three,
you get seven-halves h nu.
The other thing to notice is
that these states are equally
spaced.
The energy spacing between any
two adjacent states is h times
nu.
That is incorrect.
What I am drawing,
here, is right.
I am sorry about that.
One-half h nu is
from the bottom of the well to v
equal zero.
I think I know what happened.
What I have shown you here is
correct.
What is in your notes is
printed incorrectly.
You should make note of that
and change that.
Suppose we have a molecule in
the v equal zero state,
where the energy is one-half h
nu,
that molecule can be excited to
the v equal one state.
That molecule in v equal zero
is still vibrating,
but we can make it vibrate even
faster, with more energy.
The same cycles per second,
but with more energy,
by promoting it to v equal one.
We can do that if the molecule
absorbs a photon.
And the energy of that photon
has to be equal to the
difference in the energies of
these two states.
So, if the final energy,
here, of the v equal one state,
that is the final state,
if that energy is three-halves
h nu and the energy
of the initial state was
one-half h nu,
then the difference in energy
between the states is h nu.
We have to have a photon that
has exactly this energy
different, delta E.
That delta E,
then, has to be gotten by a
photon with a frequency equal to
nu.
And the frequency of that
photon that is going to make
that transition is actually also
the fundamental frequency of the
molecule.
We are lucky on this one.
Nu is delta E over h.
We have to have a photon with
that frequency for the molecule
to be promoted from v equal zero
to v equal one.
How do we know what that is?
Well, we do an experiment.
We do an infrared spectroscopy
type of experiment.
The difference in the energies
between vibrational states is in
the infrared range of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
And so we are going to use
infrared radiation.
We have some source of infrared
radiation.
It puts out all different
frequencies in the infrared.
And then we send it through a
monochromator.
The monochromator disperses
that radiation in space and
allows only a certain frequency
of radiation to come right
through the slits and out into
our sample.
It is like you had the
diffraction glasses,
where we disbursed the
radiation in space.
Well, a monochromator is
essentially the same thing.
There is a diffraction grading
in it.
It allows, out of the front
end, only radiation of a certain
frequency to come out.
And we can adjust what that
radiation is or what frequency
that radiation has.
We then allow it to pass
through our sample,
say HCl.
And then there is photo
detector over here,
some kind of photomultiplier.
And what will happen is that if
this molecule is going to absorb
frequency of that radiation,
well, then the number of
photons reaching the photo
detector is going to go down.
If the frequency does not match
the frequency of the vibration
of HCl, well,
the photons go right through,
onto the detector.
But if it matches,
then the molecule absorbs those
photons and they never make it
to the detector.
So, a plot looks like this.
This is the intensity at the
detector versus the frequency of
the radiation.
The intensity will be high,
but now at some frequency,
which will turn out to be the
vibrational frequency of the
molecule, the intensity goes
down low.
And then, as you go to higher
frequency, the intensity comes
back up.
Right here, the molecule has
made the transition from v equal
zero to v equal one because the
frequency of that photon matches
the energy difference between v
equal zero and v equal one
divided by h.
It also happens to be the
fundamental frequency of the
molecule for HCl.
So, that is how we know what
those fundamental frequencies
are.
Let's now look at what those
energies are.
We have gone from v equal zero
to v equal one.
Delta E equal h nu. We just
measured nu as 8.6x10^13 inverse
seconds.
Multiply it by h.
That is going to give us delta
E.
The difference in energy
between the two states is
5.7x10^-20 joules.
If I turn that into kilojoules
per mole, that is 35 kilojoules
per mole.
That is the energy difference
from here to here,
about 35 kilojoules per mole.
How strong is the HCl bond?
Well, the HCl bond from here to
here is about 420 kilojoules per
mole.
This is about a tenth,
a little bit less than a tenth
of the total bond strength for
HCl.
If we make it vibrate,
we are not going to make that
bond break.
It is an order of magnitude
less energy here than what you
need to break that bond.
Now, here is something that is
a little confusing.
These fundamental frequencies,
it turns out that we actually
use a different convention to
label them, different units.
We do not use Hertz very often
to talk about the fundamental
frequencies of molecules.
We use something called a
wavenumber instead of hertz.
A wavenumber is an inverse
centimeter, centimeter to the
minus one power.
The symbol for a wavenumber is
a frequency sign with a bar on
top of it.
That is a wave number.
How do we get a wavenumber?
Well, we get a wavenumber by
taking the frequency in Hertz,
inverse seconds,
and dividing it by the speed of
light.
But the speed of light,
of course, has to be in
centimeters per second.
The seconds cancel,
and what we have then left is
inverse centimeters.
For example,
if the fundamental frequency of
HCl was 8.6x10^13 hertz,
we divide that by the speed of
light in centimeters per second
and the wavenumbers,
or the fundamental frequency in
wavenumbers, then,
is 2,886 wavenumbers for HCl.
These are the common units that
are used to talk about the
fundamental vibrational
frequencies of molecules.
And these are the common
numbers used to discuss infrared
spectra of molecules.
This unit of a wavenumber.
It is a non-SI unit.
In other words,
what you will often see is an
infrared spectrum intensity at
the photodiode,
now, versus wave number.
And right at 2,886 wavenumbers,
that is the fundamental
frequency in wavenumbers.
That is where the molecule
makes the transition from v
equal zero to v equal one.
Now, the question is,
what determines the frequency
of the vibration of a molecule?
Well, what determines the
frequency of that vibration,
and here, I have now gone back
to frequency because I am
writing it in terms of some
other parameters,
are two parameters.
One is the force constant k,
and the other is the mass.
What I have here is the reduced
mass.
I will explain that to you in
just a moment,
but this is essentially the
mass.
The frequency is given by one
over 2pi times the square root
of this k, the force constant
over the mass.
sqrt(k / m)**
That force constant,
k, is a measure of the
stiffness of the spring.
Another words,
if you have a very stiff
spring, k is very large.
That is you need a lot of force
to pull that spring apart,
a lot of force to compress that
spring.
A large k means you have a very
stiff spring.
If you have a small k,
that means you have a very weak
spring.
It does not take very much
force to stretch that spring or
to compress that spring.
So k is a measure of the
stiffness of the spring.
It also tells us something
about the shape of the
interaction energy.
Another words,
what k actually tells us here
is kind of the width of this
well.
Here is my interaction energy,
potential well.
If you have a very narrow
width, this is a large k.
If you have a very broad width,
here, this is a small k.
So, k, the force constant,
tells us about the shape,
here, of this well.
Very narrow well,
large k.
Very broad well,
small k.
Now, I think that maybe you
have seen this before in 8.01.
Have you done the harmonic
oscillator yet?
No?
Yes?
Some yes.
Some no.
Mostly no, it sounds to me.
This expression,
here, for the frequency,
you are going to see in 8.01
some time.
It comes from the harmonic
oscillator model.
You will remember that you have
seen this before.
Those of you who have know what
I am talking about.
Those of you who have not,
just remember you are going to
see this very soon once again.
Now, the other parameter here
that is important is this mu
here, this reduced mass.
What the reduced mass is,
is essentially the mass.
Now, if you had already done
this in 8.01,
what you are going to look at
is a mass on the end of a spring
attached to a wall.
There will be a wall,
then you will see a spring,
and then there will be some
mass m.
When you do this problem as a
harmonic oscillator,
you are going to write nu here
as k over this mass right there.
But, in this example,
this mass here is the only body
that is moving.
Your wall is still.
But, in the case of a molecule,
both atoms are moving.
What mass do we use?
Well, the fact that both are
moving means we have a two body
problem.
And we are going to have to
change the coordinate system to
take into account that both
masses are moving.
We can do that easily.
And doing that easily involves
using something called the
reduced mass.
The reduced mass takes a two
body problem and reduces it to a
single body, where the single
body is this fictitious body
with a mass given by the reduced
mass.
It is exact.
I did not make any
approximations here.
But the bottom line is that
this reduced mass is simply the
mass of one atom,
times the mass of the other,
divided by the sum of the two
masses.
And sometimes a useful
approximation is when one of the
masses is much lower than the
other mass, so when m1 here is
smaller than m2.
Well, you can see in that case,
if m1 is very small compared to
m2, we are going to treat it
like a zero.
And then these two m's are
going to cancel.
You can see the reduced mass is
roughly equivalent to the mass
of the smaller body.
Sometimes I will ask you to use
that approximation.
Other times,
I will ask you to calculate the
reduced mass.
Let's look at some frequencies
for some molecules,
here.
I have an array of molecules.
All of them roughly have the
same force constant.
I am going to look at the mass
dependence on the fundamental
frequency.
I have got the frequencies
written both in terms of wave
numbers and Hertz.
The first thing I want you to
notice is the fundamental
frequency for hydrogen,
4,159 wave numbers.
That is the highest vibrational
frequency that we know about.
Why is it so high?
Well, because those two
hydrogens are so light,
and the mass is in the
denominator of that fundamental
frequency.
So if it is in the denominator,
it is small,
and the fundamental frequency
is going to be high.
Then look at these molecules,
HCl, HBr, HI.
In this case here,
it is all a hydrogen bonded to
a halogen.
For the most part,
the reduced mass of these three
molecules is that of hydrogen.
If that is of hydrogen,
since that is in the
denominator for the expression
for the frequency,
well, the frequencies are going
to be high in general.
And they are,
2,886, 2,559.
Not as high as molecular
hydrogen, but still pretty high.
And then we look at these three
molecules, chlorine,
bromine, iodine.
Both particles very heavy.
The reduced mass is large.
Look at what happened to the
frequency here.
The frequency really has gone
down much lower than it was for
HCl, HBr or HI.
So, that is one parameter.
The other parameter,
of course, is the force
constant.
Here are a set of molecules
that have all roughly the same
reduced mass,
fluorine, oxygen,
NO.
And I have written down their
frequencies, both in wave
numbers and Hertz.
For molecular fluorine,
which has a single bond,
that frequency here is pretty
low, 892 wave numbers.
It is pretty low.
This is a single bond,
which is easy to stretch.
It is not very stiff.
It is a loose bond,
so to speak.
But now, look at oxygen and NO.
They have double bonds,
which are stiffer.
If they are stiffer,
k is larger,
the fundamental frequency is
higher.
Then, we look at CO and
nitrogen.
They have triple bonds,
which are even stiffer.
Stiffer bonds,
larger k, higher fundamental
frequency, that are those two
parameters that dictate the
frequency of vibration.
We will do rotation on
Wednesday.
See you then.